Huff's gum resumes beautiful dad dammit
today we're gonna play some oculus rift
horror games let's just do this really
quick and hopefully it's over soon
you don't know what it's like alright
alright let's try it out that's great
press spacebar ready to continue Wow I'm
driving a cab I don't have any friends
this is just like really amazing the
head tracking isn't working that's
actually kind of nice I can do 360s well
what's going on what's that sound oh my
god I just killed a woman ah who cares
got it fine what are you doing here
we're in the middle of the road oh my
god I've never been so scared in my life
okay find the church don't know why but
I crashed so why not oh god it is
actually [ __ ] scary over the oculus
even though it's a [ __ ] game man
hello trees and forest of the night
please don't hurt me thank you very very
kindly what is this charge you speak up
and must be behind these trees I'm so
lost already I literally just started
playing this is not okay oh I can't I
can't play on the ah it's too scary oh
my god it's not even like if it was
without the oculus no big deal but it's
riding my face and it feels like it's
there it is fairly okay wait oh my god
I'm such a [ __ ] [ __ ] it you know what
get in there you're a man you can do
this alright
oh my god my nips are harder than the
hardest diamond ever crafted well that
[ __ ] died not my fault
whoo that's what she find the church but
I'm like where the [ __ ] is the church
I'd seriously hurt my fingers from
pulling out the oculus that's how much
you hurt my feelings
mainly my feelings actually did hurt a
lot let's check out over here where the
[ __ ] is the [ __ ] Church Oh God okay
so there's lights over here so I'm gonna
guess it's over here please for the love
of God be here don't want to run into
that man sir again all right just don't
not a big fan of him don't think he's in
Vic five run I can't run it's not fair
it's not [ __ ] fair she has tense it's
not okay just go hey yo what did I do to
deserve this [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
keep running you run like a [ __ ]
turtle someone in your family is a
[ __ ] turtle I'm not looking
back all right I'm just not doing that
[ __ ] just keep running
oh that's great someone is coming for my
help
what about [ __ ] me I have it what
what what what trees trees I'm itching
like someone is pinching me with a
thousand needles in my butt come on man
to [ __ ] up ha it's just the game its
just the game is just the game it's not
scary not scary at all I am a man
and men are supposed to not be scared
because why I don't know what that
sexist all right you know what I feel
violated
Hayden okay [ __ ] the trees man [ __ ] the
trees I never been a hater of the trees
but I am as of today okay all right
differ in the fairest we will get away
fan-fucking-tastic why I don't know how
I guess we're just gonna do it shut your
[ __ ] mouth hole all right we got this
I hear a baby crying that's a great sign
to get the [ __ ] out of here I see
something over there could that be
possibly be the church oh my god I think
I think we've made it all right I'm just
gonna go inside because I think that
[ __ ] monster is out there oh my god
oh my god oh my god I can't no I can all
right
all right it's fine this game it's a
game it's game it's game it's a game
that's gave it's a game it's a game this
game it's a game it's game it's a game
it's a game it's a game it's a game it's
a game it's a game okay okay all right
Oh God no no no no no and no what no
what no what no what no no no no no no
no no no okay hello that hello that
it'll go Oh what the [ __ ] why I'm laying
down now okay oh oh I was on a day my
check tab Terry on that eye isn't that
right honey
well I'm alone god dammit it's a
nightmare whoa Oh what the [ __ ]
oh no don't don't just don't please I am
I never hurt a bug me oh god maybe just
one bug but Jesus Christ are discussing
honey are you all right there oh that
was pretty fun it was like it wasn't it
was
for now it was pretty sketchy but it was
[ __ ] effective man this this right
here
it's the future of horror games like no
doubt in my mind it's such a difference
with the oculus you bros have no idea
you can call me [ __ ] all you want but
it's something else all right it is
something else
thank you for liking on this video I
appreciate it bros and thank you for
hanging out with me today I'll see you
tomorrow
brofist